now just to correct the record i am
never greased up you will see sweat
but i am never wearing any kind of
oil or anything like that when i work
out
governor suggested otherwise nothing but
respect not true
it's it's okay you can deny this it's
fine i mean later on we can talk about
it privately about
what kind of oil you used and all that
stuff it was coconut oil i was told but
anyway
let's forget about it come on chris
everyone knows
you put the oil on after the workout
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy tuesday everyone it is tuesday
right
yeah cat is recuperating after a minor
commuting accident
oh that's what i was afraid of
that wasn't really her anyway in for her
is emily compagno
who was just on the 5 recently
are you guys happy friday we're so
excited to be here on the five
me and jessica and jesse and shannon and
greg
they will all be here any minute and
we'll see you guys
what's so funny all right so you
remember the sports illustrated
swimsuit issue it's the one that has
about much to do with sports as
i do i was more of a better homes and
gardens kind of guy
i wasn't the best at landing a free
throw but damn i could landscape a
backyard
in more ways than one chadwick
[Laughter]
i bring up that old magazine because
like hunter biden it's now trying hard
to change for their 2021 swimsuit
edition they featured three stars on the
cover a tennis pro naomi osaka
a rapper megan the stallion and trans
activist laina bloom
the magazine has ticked more boxes than
a meth head doing his
sats but damn that's going to confuse
the 90 year olds who still subscribe to
the once legendary magazine
but it's perfect for it's designed as
outraged theater for the right
and noble approval seeking from the left
and both work hand in hand to help
sports illustrated prop up their brand
like the corpse in weekend at bernie's
but because the desperation for
relevance is so
obvious the consumer shrugs people know
a participation trophy when they see one
while their peers in the media applaud
their enlightened editorial perspective
the average guy in gal rules their eyes
their disbelieving eyes
it's happening everywhere sports
politics life in general
everything's woke it's no longer about
reality it's the perception of inclusion
and exclusion
that changes the definition of reality
and any resistance is seen as bigoted
hateful and reactionary now i get the
tennis pro
but like the equipment she uses the rest
of this wokism
is a racket thank you hence the
connection between trans activism and
sports illustrated
especially when the magazine ignores the
elephant in the room which is the impact
of male to female trans athletes on
female sports the trans model cover
protects them
but it's a fair question would she have
been on the cover if she wasn't trans
but asking that question is like asking
why a sports magazine
cover would have swimsuits in the first
place i never understood this
i like to keep my general interest in me
looking at half
naked women separates i mean imagine if
popular mechanics had a swimsuit issue
i mean i wouldn't mind i have a thing
for plumbers and they're ball [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that controls the flow of water in a
toilet tank people
[Laughter]
thank you but thanks to the trans cover
the s hi staff looks woke as opposed to
a bunch of dirty old drooling editors
and it gets activists off your back
really easily it's like a shop owner
spray painting
blm or with you on the plywood
protecting their window
appear woke and the twitter mob might
let you survive otherwise they'll topple
you like a statue of abe lincoln
the women's magazines got this early on
putting plus size models on their covers
they did this because they knew for
decades their obsession with rail thin
mannequins
led to eating disorders all the editors
are still obsessed over being thin
but now they use heavier models as a
shameless stab at enlightenment
obesity has its own health risks but
bring that up
shame on you for fat shaming it's not
about the needs of the readers or
viewers anyway the media is the only
industry that holds barely disguised
contempt for their customers
they're no different than chinese
fentanyl producers cell phone companies
and any government employee that is
supposed to help you
it's now about creating a virtue
signaling stew to placate terrified
advertisers sports illustrated just one
example
of an effort to blend in in order to
escape the wrath victoria's secret
dropped their iconic angels calling them
unattainable which is the whole point
of supermodels they aren't supposed to
be attainable
like you and me or else they would be
attainable
it's the true symbol of inequality the
real discrimination in life
is between levels of physical appeal not
race
but that was the point of the angels
right they were quite literally
out of this world but now we want women
grounded
in real life victoria's secret says so
who are their new models well
not models it's their brand ambassadors
and they are
soccer player megan rapinoe transgender
model valentina sampio
and plus size model paloma el seltzer
among a few others so is that grounded
in real life
maybe i have no idea i'm a stone cold
superfreak
try me and i love being grounded in real
life
but if you mean it then just skip the
teddies and sell
sweatpants don't sell me extended
expensive lingerie that's grounded in
reality
if i want that i'll rummage through
killmead's office
oh stuff he has is disgusting
don't forget once the woke police take
over every aspect of what we consume
there's no telling where it'll stop you
can almost picture it
here again what is it this time huh what
is it this time
did you or did you not tweet out i wish
the sports illustrated swimsuit issue
stayed the same
what's so wrong with enjoying women in
swimsuits yeah i said that
that's sexist and objectifying next
you'll be telling us you enjoy reading
about sports coverage let me tell you
something we went through your recycling
bin
perhaps you'd care to explain this oh my
god well
i like cars like cars fewer than three
percent of the vehicles in here are
electric
don't you care about global warming guys
come on
geez and also maybe you care to explain
this oh my god give me a break it's my
wife's magazine she's a woman
your wife is a woman that's very gender
binary and you know damn well that women
have not had their day
and maybe you'd like to explain this
what people
people as in you people
oh thank god you're here i object ramps
to logan or habeas corpus
subpoena affy david plead the fifth
beyond a reasonable doubt
why why do you let them bring you here
all the time come on let's get out of
here
i knew you weren't a real lawyer but in
today's culture as seen through the
distorted lens of the media everything
old is bad
and everything woke is good i'd say keep
it going it's time to normalize
everything we once considered impossible
i always wanted to be on the cover of
sports illustrated
maybe it's my time
love periods welcome tonight's guest
she's the vegan who's got a beef with
everyone fox business network anchor
taking mcdowell
when the press needs a right turn he
grabs the wheel right turn strategies
president chris barron
he's burned more bridges than general
sherman outspoken editor chief chadwick
moore
now when this former cheerleader says
2468
it's me who she appreciates outnumbered
co-host
emily campagno
dagan why can't straight cis normative
males like me
be on the cover of the swimsuit issue i
think i would look gate
great in a bikini or a mankini
i do i've seen the selfies that you take
in your private time
yes i love how that sports illustrated
is moving into this century but their
idea of progress
is well a woman in a bathing suit
standing on the beach
right on her knees in the sand with her
legs spread
yes you know we're rising up except
we're not
because we're on all fours with our ass
stuck up in the air
listen i went through the photos in this
sports illustrated and it's true
so women can rule the world except
if we're covered in lotion and have sand
in our crack
and you talked about it at least sports
illustrated still has all these
what did you call them unattainable
models on the
inside pages i will say that bravery is
wearing a bathing suit that is laid a
bikini that's laced across the middle
and not having your like kidney fat
hanging over the laces so
kudos that is the true hero when you
think about it
i don't know chadwick it's kind of funny
watching companies
kind of fall over themselves to blend
like they're covering their asses by
trying to look like they are the most
enlightened but it's it just
do they believe it or are they oh good
question
we i think the jury is still out if they
believe it or not if they're still
gauging if it's good for business
yeah you know uh just sometimes it isn't
some i think you're right that with the
sports illustrated well here we are
talking about sports illustrated
and they did this again if you uh uh
previously a few years ago and they put
a fat person a fat woman on the in the
sprint suit issue use me plus either
excu
a person of obesity yes on on the cover
but yeah we're talking about the
swimsuit issue which was something that
you know maybe
should have gone away when with the
internet but it's good for business so
that is true that seems like something
that should have been killed by the
internet since it's killed everything
else including
like three of my jobs i mean i told you
i worked for maxim
not everybody here would be like what's
that yeah yeah i remember maximum you
were yeah yeah
i was an editor of max and that was one
of the things that just kind of floated
off into the ether
along with stuff magazine it was the
internet and not you that killed max
some people will argue that i was i was
probably the killer
what do you make of this trend chris
well one i'd like to point out that you
have two gay men on here to talk about
the sports illustrated swimsuit issue
which i find entertaining
yes but i will opine on it anyways and
you also have two women
who identify as gay men that's actually
true
yeah is that because you're still saying
that all the time
what i thought was funny was they
actually described the the the trans
model as their first
openly trans model and my question was
have they had another
like trans country that like wasn't
openly trained like
should we going back through former si
models and asking them is
is there something you want to tell us
like i totally missed that that's a very
keen insight
that's that's why i'm here inside
but you're a crazy sports fan i am
you're right
which is why i don't read sports
illustrated did you used to yeah way
back in the day when you had to get like
information from usa today or sports
illustrated like all of those things are
now irrelevant
and chad was right chadwick's right
there we're talking about this
you know sports illustrated which
normally no one does
because frankly sports illustrated's
been dead for 15 years see i don't
see i disagree with the idea of media
attention i don't
i think they do this not to get any
attention
because the fear is that they will be
called out for misogyny or sexism
and what this has done what this does is
it's it's
they paid the over over pri overpaid
consultants they've got the diversity
they got all that stuff
so that they don't make a ripple so that
they can squeeze by and the advertisers
don't get scared emily how
are you so good it's so great
[Laughter]
right so i have a question for you were
once an nfl cheerleader back what in the
70s right
yeah a little before that yeah and
stabler used to hit on you
the snake yeah the snake um you know he
got that name digging
you know um plumbing plumbing
he would snake through the the field
right yeah
yeah r.i.p um here's my question
and it may not even be a question maybe
it's an opinion
it seems to me that what they're trying
to shut down is anything that kind of
indulges the straight male
gaze right it's like it's more like uh
anything that a straight guy is
attracted to is kind of the problem
and is that going to happen with
cheerleading in general because anything
like it
it's that's going to be the next step or
maybe it already is and i've missed it
it's already been happening so the
washington football team essentially
just dismantled
their cheerleading squad and has before
that completely overhauled it
to put on sort of different more like
tracksuit looking
uniforms and the like so the answer was
essentially to you feel more
tempted by this and there are thus
allegations of sexual harassment
will be to extinguish the temptation i
think your point about this playing into
the the woke gods essentially to prevent
their being
the culture mob coming out of them is
totally true i mean think about it there
are three covers
here they want to make sure all the
boxes are checked and to the transgender
point
laina is not an athlete but there are in
fact a million transgender athletes out
there we've been seeing them not only
through high school sports and the
subject
of a lot of legislation but also at the
olympic level so the fact that there are
global
you know parameters set to that right
now but that's the one that they're
going to choose because it's the safe
play because they're not actually
getting into the frame very smart
because why didn't they actually go with
the athlete
right um there's one reason that's right
well and i'll tell you why because the
the
i said this briefly in the monologue the
real the most pervasive discrimination
on earth is something we all
know it goes back to natural selection
it's
attraction and beauty people that are
lucky to be born with cheekbones
go much further no matter the race than
anybody else which is why i'm very lucky
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else